there are a few really common pitfalls
that developers should avoid first and
foremost it's using your analytics
improperly a good example of this is
relying on vanity metrics vanity metrics
are things such as daily active users
these might be extremely large
attractive numbers a hundred thousand a
million people but they don't actually
tell you how the app or the game is
performing you might have a huge number
of people but nobody's actually
monetizing or the percentage of people
that are monetizing even though the
average revenue per user is really high
the percentage of total people who are
making a purchase is absurdly low you're
leaving money on the table so make sure
that you're not relying on those vanity
metrics make sure you're tracking
exactly the right things it's only
things that actually determine whether
or not you're making money or retaining
users it might be interesting to see how
many people are engaging with a
multiplayer feature within your game but
if it's not actually contributing to
your monetization the percentage of
people that are making a purchase or
sticking around or say sharing the game
with their friends then it makes the
most sense to leave that out of your
analysis finally when looking at your
analytics make sure you're not getting
consumed with the minutia in a lot of
cases there will be a great degree of
noise but not a whole lot of signal
particularly statistically significant
signal so make sure that in the end if
you see small day to day or week to week
fluctuations that you're only acting on
it if it's actually something that is
significant one mistake that we see a
lot is that developers rely on one
particular ad network or monetization
method for all of their monetization you
don't want to put all of your eggs in
one basket so even if you have a great
relationship with whoever the person is
that sold you that particular method
make sure that there are fall backs just
in case there's a problem finally don't
use emotion or rely on emotion in order
to make your decisions do everything
based on the numbers there's great data
somewhere out there that's going to
determine exactly what's right for you
all you have to do is find it